life behind the mask comes with plenty
of challenges especially when it comes
to reading emotions but could it also be
creating new ways of communicating
take a look they've become the symbol of
the pandemic as well as the isolation
that it's brought face masks studies
show that they can help protect us from
the corona virus as we go about our
daily lives but they can also keep us
from understanding one another something
is different it takes me longer to work
out whether someone is happy to see me
or whether they agree with me basically
and get less information psychologically
for to pilots to be able to work as a
team it's critically important to be
able to read your colleagues emotions in
anandhan I went to the doctor and
noticed that it was really hard going at
the reception I had to work hard to show
that I had a hearing impairment and that
I was having difficulties communicating
when the nurse understood she was quick
to suggest that we remove our masks as
we cover our faces and practice social
distancing our face masks making us
socially distant join now by Ralph and
dick he's a professor of social
psychology at Goethe University in
Frankfurt
which is where he joins me from welcome
Ralph a first question are we losing
connection are we losing connection with
one another because of these face masks
yes that might be one of the problem of
the face marks our research very clearly
shows that social connection is
extremely important and during the days
of the hard work out we we weren't able
to get in touch with each other and now
we do face masks what is missing is
mimics facial expressions and we humans
have learned in millions of years of our
evolution to read into each other's
faces and this is very important the
information that it's missing now so do
you think people are learning new ways
of communicating with one another if
they can't see those expressions I
sometimes try to observe myself and I
try to communicate much more with my
eyes and my eyebrow
when I was when I am very math so it
depends a little bit on how long this
will continue if we have to wear the
mass in public for the next couple of
months maybe then we clearly learn these
new techniques yes is it fair to say
that face masks represent just one
aspect of a larger problem during this
pandemic and it is social isolation yes
that's right face masks are just a
visible sign of it but I think the
social isolation phenomena are much more
severe and a much wider or broader than
the face mask alone so people who do not
live in families who do not live in in
larger communities have learned to to
not seeing their colleagues their
friends their relatives for two or three
months and this is a huge problem
you've mentioned also in the past
physical contact basic physical contact
something that we try and avoid with
many people right now that's also a form
of isolation to not have that correct
that's right and I mean it's a cultural
issue I was visiting China a couple of
years ago and and right afterwards was
in Japan so Chinese keep context much
more than Japanese for granted ooh
German are probably somewhere in the
middle and and so it's a difficult thing
if you are not used to that situation
not being able to touch each other
it feels awkward and and we humans also
learned in our years of many million
years of evolution to to to console each
other by physical touch and contact what
kind of a psychological burden is that
put on people to have to forgo a lot of
these social interactions I think it
puts a huge burden on our studies
starting in the 1950s that have shown
that children who were hospitalized for
a few months or longer because of severe
illnesses had severe impairments of
their
cognitive but also the social
development we are working together on a
corona project with people from 10
different countries and just now the
data from Kazakhstan came in in
Kazakhstan between mid March and late
late May more than 800 people have
killed themselves compared to only 14 in
the year before so that signal said
something is going on we don't know yet
whether it also is because some people
have financial worries or other
stressors but I think social isolation
is a big factor contributing to that all
right an easily overlooked aspect of the
pandemic professor Ralph and dick from
go to University and Frankfurt thank you
for joining us and time now to answer
your questions about kovat 19 over to
our science correspondent derrick
williams how will those who sustained
long-term damage from Kovach 19 respond
to the flu this fall a lot of experts
are worried that this winter we're going
to see this kind of perfect respiratory
disease storm that a feared second wave
of kovat 19 will will coincide with the
yearly flu season now if that happens it
could easily easily bring health systems
really to the brink when it comes to
influenza one of the one of the most
vulnerable populations in the coming
fall of winter will unquestionably be
those people who have already been been
ravaged by kovat 19 for them catching
the flu in the months ahead could
quickly turn life-threatening that's one
reason why doctors are encouraging as
many people as possible to get a flu
shot this year most especially those who
suffered badly from Kovan 19 and might
have sustained lung damage from it a flu
shot won't provide perfect protection
but it's it's it's much much better than
nothing
contests differentiate between Tsar's
Cove - and the corona viruses that cause
colds this is a little complicated so
stick with me when it comes to testing
you have to distinguish between
sensitivity and specificity now
sensitivity describes how likely a test
is to to properly detect an infection
with the virus so so it affects what are
called false negative results some
specificity on the other hand describes
how likely or unlikely a test is to
confuse the virus it's supposed to
detect with another one and and report
that someone is carrying the virus when
they actually aren't that's called a
false positive result now although the
polymerase chain reaction or PCR tests
that are being widely used in the
pandemic are highly specific their
sensitivity can vary depending on for
example how the sample was collected so
some what that means in clear terms is
that if you take a test and it turns out
positive you're very likely to have the
disease if it comes up negative however
that's not an ironclad guarantee you
don't have the disease test sensitivity
is improving all the time but it's not
perfect what do you think of Sweden's
approach Swedish health authorities have
taken a risk with their unique approach
to the pandemic um they didn't force
businesses or schools to close and the
national strategy has been to strike
what the government calls a sustainable
compromise while protecting people at
the greatest risk but but a pretty high
death toll there particularly among the
elderly has made a lot of people both
inside and outside the country
questioned and criticized what's going
on and as Europe opens its borders
Swedes are being barred from some other
European countries and and and told that
if they travel there they're going to
have to quarantine in others so I
personally
really think it's still too early to say
whether Sweden made the right choice or
not I mean if we develop effective
vaccines and treatments soon it'll
probably look like the wrong one if we
but if we don't in a year or two it
could look like the only approach that
really worked
[Music]